but you got to tell the story from
saturday night live days a lot of people
like
maybe know that conan worked on saturday
night live as a writer and stuff
mm-hmm george steinbrenner is the host
of saturday night live that week in 19.
oh my gosh
well basically this is what happened it
wasn't even my idea on cern not live the
monologue is the thing that
rarely comes together until the last
second and
often you know if it's a comedian if
it's say a jerry seinfeld or a will
ferrell or if it's a john mullaney
they have a great monologue or an adam
sandler they show up really well
prepared they know the deal
but when you're dealing with someone
who's a civilian right
they don't know that the monologue is
important they also don't know that no
one's thought about it
and that it's they're going to get
jerked around all week until the last
second
and isn't that mind-blowing to someone
like you who you go like oh my god i've
spent my entire life thinking about what
i might say on camera at any given
moment
and then you meet people who go like hey
i'll just go on saturday night live and
and i don't care about the monologue but
it's yeah are the writers
but also i think it's not all their
fault because they assume that
they assume falsely that these are
professionals right they're going to
take good care of me and
and we didn't when i was at turnout live
we didn't always take care of people
right you know we sometimes [ __ ] up
and we didn't take care of people
so jordan steinbrenner's on yeah and
this is george steinbrenner and he was
at the
height of you know he's george
steinbrenner the yankees he's the cliche
that you know from seinfeld
larry david played we want to look to
the future we've got to tear down the
past
babe ruth was nothing more than a fat
old man with little girl legs
and we were all scared of him we were
all terrified no one had thought of the
monologue and then there was some idea
for a monologue that wasn't even my idea
and it it became like doing kp duty
in the in the service it was like
someone take care of this and i remember
lauren saying conan go talk to and go
talk to steinbrenner and pitch in this
idea for a monologue you know and i
don't even remember what the idea was
and what i didn't know is that he had
been pitched this idea already and said
no
so i remember i went in and bob odenkirk
and i were like the young writers
were kids we go into this room i have to
do the talking
my voice was even higher then than it is
now and i would go in and i'm like
it's just time better um yeah so this
idea for the monologue where you like
come out
and you lost the keys to the car and you
think maybe
you know and he said i already i told
you
i told you i don't want to do that idea
i already said i don't want to do that
idea and i remember what i remembered is
he had this
massive world series ring the biggest
ring i've ever seen in my life
big figures and he looks like he has
about 60 pounds of corned beef in his
colon you know one of those
yeah beefy guys big german guys he's
like i don't want to
do this and i totally said i don't want
to do it i don't want to do it and so i
just
odin kirk and i retreat out of the room
and our testicles had gone up inside our
bodies
and we go and we tell lorne and we say
to lauren he doesn't want norm went you
know you just have to go back
you just have to go back and tell him
you just have to go back and tell him
look it's a good idea and you've lost
the car keys and then
and then you know it's a funny thing and
he'll understand and so lauren just
wanted this problem to go away so he
sent us back
oh so we go back into his little
dressing room so he's even
bigger because he's in a tiny space it's
like we're getting into a phone booth
with george steinbrenner
to tell him unpleasant news we go into
this tiny room
he sees the two of us and i go this is
time runner
um okay well we just think the thing
with the keys could be funny
because if you think about it and
steinbrenner just turned around and said
we literally went right through the wall
like ghosts
and i don't think we spoke for a week